search teams are literally climbing
mountains to find the black boxes from a
boeing 737 jet that crashed yesterday in
southeastern china
132 people were on that flight and so
far there are no signs of survivors this
is china's first deadly plane crash
since 2010 the boeing jet was just seven
years old seth doan has more on the
story
rescuers in southern china are
continuing to search the hilly rough
terrain where that china eastern
airlines 737 800 crashed after its
nearly vertical nose dive from the sky
this chilling surveillance footage may
have captured the final moments of the
flight this video circulating on social
media has not been verified tracking
data shows the plane departed the
chinese city of kunming early monday and
had been flying at roughly 29 000 feet
before plummeting to 8 000 feet in just
over a minute the aircraft then briefly
climbed about a thousand feet before the
data abruptly ends about 40 seconds
later robert sumwalt is a former
chairman of the national transportation
safety board i think it's very important
to point out that this is not the 737
max that was grounded three years ago
because of two accidents this is the 737
800 which is an earlier model of the 737
it has a very good safety record
crashes during the cruise phase of
flight are reportedly rare is there any
early
idea of what a possible cause might be
well the good thing is is an airplane
like this has has data that is
transmitted on about once every second i
think that the investigators will have a
good idea of what happened
as loved ones wait for answers china
eastern has grounded all of its 737 800s
for cbs morning's seth doan london
my biggest fear the terror that those
people must have experienced on that
plane very very very sorry